welcome welcome to another you talk wall
in the first movie / book where people
don't have to argue about what the
titles supposed to be chamber of secrets
it's what it is everywhere damn it I'm
gonna find out it's like closet of
Secrets somewhere oh well I tried
[Music]
Harry Potter and the Chamber of Secrets
that's right in my quest to become the
Potter right I once was my marathon of
Harry Potter watching and Harry Potter
reviews continues here is Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets is the second
year for Harry Hermione and Ron Bobby
this little elf comes to Harry Potter
he's like you can't come to Hogwarts
this year you don't really know why
everything goes wrong for him but flying
car and now he's in Hogwarts and now
there's a mystery that's what I really
liked about those ones Harry Potter in
the Chamber of Secrets is a solid and
proper sequel takes what you learned
from the first movie expands the lore
you learn new things not just about the
spells but the people the ideology among
the people you learn more about the
founders of the houses in this place
called the Chamber of Secrets supposedly
someone is opening the Chamber of
Secrets no one knows how or why and
Harry gets this weird book that he can
write in and then it talks back to him
is there an app for that
like is there a Tom Riddle's diary app
because that would be so awesome writing
to the why would that's right the first
movie is a great introduction to a very
magical world this one's like all right
you'll learn things about Voldemort and
that one hears more about him and the
people who followed him and a lot of
these themes really hit because you know
again where they're going whole like
pure wizards versus impure wizards I was
like okay I guess that's whatever come
on kid to the chamber cigarettes but now
seeing the saga looking back they're
like no that's very important it's kind
of the point of the whole war that we're
about to have it has a really creepy
spider scene also someone who is not a
fan of spiders well it's that same
mm-hmm we also get to see pop and Malfoy
jason isaacs plays Lucius Malfoy Draco
Malfoy's father dudes a complete pompous
dick and he plays it so well sometimes
he's over cooking it in times he's like
you for the movie being about two and a
half hours long there are moments where
it dips and you're like alright I just I
need some answer give me something I
need a saga this very world building us
with the sequel run into the first one
you're so enchanted you're like oh my
god there's new stuff this one gives you
more new stuff but it's not completely
new anymore there's something so magical
about John Williams score for Harry
Potter once again in Chamber of Secrets
like the first Harry Potter movie he
composes the musical score and there was
a time where the Harry Potter theme was
not around it's so organic and just in
your memories what's the Harry Potter
theme yeah that's right everyone knows
it
there was a time that theme was just no
where you read Harry Potter and you
don't even have that theme in your head
baffling to me it's so completely a part
of Harry Potter even when you find
Williams there's no longer a score in
the music everyone else was like yeah
we're not gonna pull an Avengers and
make a totally different theme for the
second one just because the composer of
the first one's gone
you don't just unwrite and rewrite John
Williams music he says that's the theme
that's the theme forever
you can't tell there's a thing that's
done you see this a lot in stories that
are really long you know a few chapters
long by chapters I mean installments
books or movies whatever there's that
thing that's early on we'll call it the
diary that later on they introduced
Horcrux isms like Oh we'll just make
that one of those he just tells it was
just a diary that operated how it's
explained in chamber of secrets and
later on it was like oh JK Rowling was
like you make it that she wasn't like oh
that's a Horcrux and I'll address that
in year six now if you haven't seen
Harry Potter warning I guess I'll talk
about what happens in the chamber and
the Diary of Tom Riddle and all that
pretty awesome and I want to talk about
all right you've been warned this is
straight up the usual suspects moments
of Harry Potter guys just Tom Riddle
Diaries been given Harry Clues and Tom
Riddle is down there he's like yeah okay
I'm gonna take your wand you won't need
it and he writes out Tom Marvolo riddle
and swaps all the letters around and it
shuffles around to spell I am Lord
Voldemort that's the first time you're
like oh my gosh like I would imagine
Voldemort snot his name not like his mom
was like I shall call him Voldemort
ensuring that he would be the villain
one day I love that Tom Riddle is just
such a Tom Riddle how harmless a name
can you ever have such a cool moment
such a humanizing moment for something
so evil
however Lucius Malfoy straight-up tries
to murder Harry Potter in his school he
gets really pissed to hit him and he got
he raises his wand he goes and then
Dobby stops on the continuing phrase is
Kedavra and then the kid dies because
it's an unforgivable killing curse that
he was going to do in the school and
he's fine just walks away and that's a
me back that is like someone whipping
out a gun going to a kid in a school and
then be like yeah alright fine I won't
you still were going to I'm telling
about the legal logistics of Hogwarts
it's not a place you would send your
kids to but it's a place that kids would
want to go
like did he kill the kid no he was
definitely going to though but did he
because unless he did what are you
talking about what shouldn't you arrest
him and send him to Azkaban guys in the
end Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets is a proper sequel it's a sequel
that nothing really captures the magic
and majesty of experiencing the world
for the first time but it really does
give you a fun mystery it also takes
Hogwarts to a living breathing character
of its own anytime there's a super
secret chamber of secrets that magical
people can't even find that's right the
school of Hogwarts itself now becomes a
living entity the Chamber of Secrets
Revealed was really cool I actually feel
like this movie could have been a little
shorter I personally had a great time
with this I will say Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets is definitely
worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray alright guys so Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets have you seen it
what did you think about it or how does
it compare with the first Harry Potter
movie which one is better for you
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]